antonin rousseau rivard ouvre les
lumières de son restaurant
encore une fois vide la réouverture va
être le plus grand défi de la crise le
chef propriétaire évalue le coût de la
relance de son entreprise à quelques
dizaines de milliers de dollars
ce qu'on a besoin c'est pas d'aider des
prêts et des subventions
plusieurs appréhende la fin des
subventions gouvernementales
mitch garber propose une taxe temporaire
spéciale co vide pour les plus nantis
je pense que on peut regarder des façons
que les particuliers les compagnies qui
ont vraiment bénéficier ceux qui sont
vraiment fortunés peuvent plus contribué
pendant un an ou deux mais attention
disent certaines entreprises qui ont
fleuri sous l'attendait me ils ont
[Musique]
logiquement changer les règles après
coup et de déterminer parce qu'une
entreprise très bien performé de faire
un changement poste covit du chu
trouverez ce probablement malo au canada
comme ailleurs dans le monde
l'aco vide accentue les inégalités
économiques selon le nouveau rapport
d'oxfam qui a des centaines de millions
de personnes qui vont basculer dans la
pauvreté alors que depuis des années on
est diminué la propre texte pour éviter
la spirale de la pauvreté qui touche
davantage les femmes et les personnes
racisées oxfam exige une meilleure
équité fiscale internationale
c'est à la fois nécessaire pour
l'équilibré des finances publiques ne
capacité de fonctionner et c'est aussi
une opportunité
nos opportunités je dirais comme s'en
vante pas si souvent de régler un
problème majeur en termes de fiscalité
l'argentine est l'un des premiers pays à
instaurer un impôt sur les grandes
fortunes pour lutter contre la pandémie
le pays prévoit percevoir 3 milliards de
dollars pour financer ces services
publics ici marie josée paquet comme
radio canada montréal